we now discuss how to come up with
confidence intervals when we try to
estimate the unknown mean of some random
variable or of some distribution using
the sample mean as our estimator so here
x1 up to xn are independent identically
distributed random variables that are
drawn from a distribution that has a
certain mean theta the quantity that we
want to estimate and some variance Sigma
squared let us say that we want to
construct a 95% confidence interval our
starting point will be the fact that the
sample mean according to the central
limit theorem can be described
approximately using normal distributions
and we look up at the normal table and
we observe the following that if we take
a standard normal random variable then
there is probability 97.5% of falling
below this number 1.96 which means that
there is probability two-and-a-half
percent of falling above that number and
by symmetry the probability of falling
below minus 1.96 is also two and a half
percent this means that this middle
interval here has probability 95% and we
exploit this fact as follows if we take
the sample mean subtract the true mean
and then divide by the standard
deviation of the sample mean then we
obtain a random variable which is
approximately a standard normal
therefore what we have here is the
probability of an approximately standard
normal random variable or actually it's
absolute value falling below 1.96 this
is just the event that our standard
normal falls inside this middle interval
here according to this entry from the
normal tables and the previous
discussion this probability is going to
be approximately 95%
and now we take this statement send this
term to the other side of the inequality
and then interpret what it means for an
absolute value to be less than something
and we obtain an equivalent statement
this event here is algebraically
identical to the event that we have up
there and this provides us with a
desired confidence interval we think of
this quantity here as the lower end of
the confidence interval this quantity
here is the upper end of the confidence
interval and this statement tells us
that there is probability approximately
equal to 95% that the confidence
interval constructed this way contains
the true value of the unknown parameter
so this is how we obtain a 95%
confidence interval if instead we wanted
a 90% confidence interval we would
proceed in more or less the same way
here we would want to have the number
zero point 95 why is that we want this
middle interval to have probability 90%
which means that we want to have
probability 5% at each one of the tails
and then we look up at the normal tables
and we find that the entry that gives us
probability 95% of being below that
value is 1.645
so if we use 1.645 in place of 1.96 we
obtain a 90% confidence interval and
similarly for other choices for example
if we want a 99% confidence interval
there is only one issue that's left to
discuss and this is the following in
order to obtain numerical values for the
endpoints of the confidence interval we
need to know Sigma the standard
deviation of the random variables that
we are observing but if we do not know
the value of Sigma then we may have to
do some additional work